So if you want to build like the smartest, most bulletproof financial system in the world, your first instinct is probably to just hire the absolute smartest AI models available.
Oh, absolutely. Yeah. You want the highest scores on every benchmark.
Right. You want the models that just ace every single logic test and you put them in charge. But we've got a brand new paper today that reveals this terrifying thing they call the capability paradox.
Yeah, it's a huge deal.
It really is.
Yeah.
Basically, deploying the smartest AI models can actually make the entire system drastically worse, like more likely to collapse.
Right. It completely shatters this foundational assumption we all just, you know, walk around with.
Yeah.
We're scaling these models up right now under the belief that if an individual model gets better, the whole system gets safer and more efficient. But every standard benchmark we use today evaluates model totally in isolation.
Right. Like taking a standardized test in an empty room.
Exactly. You ask a model a question, it gives you an answer. Because of that blind spot, a model can post state-of-the-art numbers on every single evil while simultaneously bringing this massive destabilizing risk floor to any system it joins.
And no current audit would even catch it.
Not a single one.
So today we are doing a deep dive into this. It's a September 2026 paper by Gillian Ross and her colleagues from MIT and the Harvard Kennedy School. And they look at LLM agents in financial markets.
Though it's worth noting, the findings apply to basically any complex system where AIs interact.
Yeah, exactly. So to understand why a room full of brilliant AI agents can like create a disaster, we have to look at the theory behind this.
Right. The background stuff.
Yeah. Back in 2021, John Kleinberg and Manish Raghavan published this paper about algorithmic monoculture.
Classic. Yeah.
Right. They proved that if two firms adopt the same highly accurate screening algorithm like an AI evaluating resumes, they can make collectively worse decisions.
Yeah.
Without any external shock even.
But Kleinberg and Raghavan were looking at a static environment, a one-shot deal.
Right. Like you screen a candidate, you hire them or you don't, and it's over.
Exactly. But what Ross and her team do here is they extend that older theory into a dynamic feedback system. They drop the AIs into an environment where they're constantly updating a shared state based on new information.
Like a stock market.
Right. And in a dynamic system, errors don't just happen once and fade away. They compound.
OK, so let's break down the actual mechanism of how those errors compound, because the authors are super specific about the math here.
They are. They split every action an AI agent takes into two parts.
Right. The first is a corrective component, basically the rational pressure moving a system toward the ground truth.
Yeah. Like if a stock is undervalued, the corrective action is to recognize that and buy it.
Makes sense. But then there's the second part, which is the non-corrective residual.
And this is literally everything else. The narrative framing the model prefers, it's learned heuristics, maybe portfolio constraints.
Or like priors it picked up during training, right?
Exactly. Stuff that's usually informative on average, but just happens to be completely wrong in this one specific context.
Okay, so to visualize this, think of a crowd at a county fair trying to guess the weight of a cow.
I love this analogy.
Right. So everyone in that crowd has independent, random biases, their non-corrective residuals. One person guesses too high because they're bad at math. Another guess is too low because of the angle they're standing at.
Right. Random human error.
Yeah. And if everyone's biases are independent, they just cancel each other out as the crowd gets bigger. The average guess gets really close to the true weight.
Exactly. The diversifiable part of the risk shrinks as you add more agents. That's the variance decomposition they talk about in the paper.
But what if they aren't independent?
Well, that's the kicker. If those residuals are positively correlated, they do not cancel out.
So, like, if everyone in the crowd is using the exact same flawed scale to weigh the cow.
Yes. Adding more people to the crowd doesn't fix the scale. The diversifiable risks shrink, sure, but that correlated part, the risk floor, it's invariant.
Meaning it literally doesn't matter how many AIs you add to the system.
No amount of scaling will remove that floor.
Wow. Okay, so that brings us to the first big test in the Ross paper, which is research question one. Do today's frontier models actually share that flawed scale?
And they went all out testing this. They set up 64 different market scenarios, varied fundamental gaps, momentum, analyst views, you name it.
And they tested seven different frontier models, right? Yeah. Which creates 21 different model pairs to compare.
Yeah. And the finding is stark. Frontier models absolutely exhibit significantly correlated non-corrective behavior.
And it gets worse, right? The correlation actually rises with capability.
It does. Average capability significantly predicted the pairwise correlation on the ELO benchmark. The R-squared was 0.475 with a p-value of 0.001.
That's a strong signal. And
it was even stronger on the MMLU Pro benchmark, R-squared of 0.580.
So basically, the smarter the models get, the more their blind spots align. But wait, if I'm running a trading firm, the obvious fix is just vendor diversity, right? Like, I'll buy one model from OpenAI, one from Anthropic, and one from Google.
You'd think so, right. But what's fascinating here is that the paper explicitly tested that, and the vendor fix entirely fails.
Wait, really?
Yeah. Sharing a provider did not predict correlation. The p-values there were .39 and .28. So
it's totally statistically irrelevant.
Completely. Two high-capability models from different companies are actually more correlated than two low-capability models from the same company.
Oh, wow. That is wild.
It is. The empirical risk floor they measured was about 0.010 against a single model residual variance of 0.021.
So the non-diversifiable floor is like half the total variance.
Yep. And it didn't fall even when they grew the ensemble size from two models up to eight.
So just buying from more vendors doesn't fix the driver of the problem at all.
Not even a little bit. And this actually confirms a 2025 paper by Kim and colleagues.
Oh, right. The one with the 350 models.
Yeah. They found that pairs of models agreed on the exact same wrong answer about 60% of the time when both erred against a one-third chance baseline. And again, larger models correlated more, even across totally different architectures.
So Ross's paper confirms Kim's empirical stuff, but adds the dynamic market consequences.
Exactly. There's also another 2025 paper by Guell and colleagues that found the same trend.
Guell, right. They used that KPA metric chance-adjusted probabilistic agreement.
That's the one. They found model mistakes get more similar as capabilities increase, but they were worried about a totally different consequence.
Right, because Guell was looking at AI oversight. Like using an LLM as a judge to grade another LLM.
Weak to strong generalization. If they share the same blind spots, oversight collapses. But Ross is looking at how this destroys market stability. Same trend, different disasters.
Right. OK, so obviously we have to ask why. Why are all these different models from different companies converging on the exact same mistakes?
Well, that is a hot debate right now. The Ross paper cites a 2024 paper by Ha and colleagues.
The platonic representation hypothesis, right?
Right. Basically argued that as models scale, they drift toward a shared statistical model of reality. Like they're all looking at the underlying structure of the universe and converging on the same platonic truth.
Even if they're trained on totally different data modalities like text versus vision.
Exactly.
But and we should definitely air this out. There's major pushback on that.
Oh, huge pushback. A 2026 paper by Kopke and colleagues literally titled Back into Plato's Cave argues with that directly.
Yeah, they say the convergence evidence is super fragile, right?
Very fragile. The original platonic paper measured alignment using mutual nearest neighbors on just, like, a thousand samples. Kopke showed that when you scale that up to millions of samples, the alignment degrades substantially.
So they're saying the models just share a coarse semantic overlap, not some deep, fine-grained structural understanding of reality.
Exactly. And Kopke also found that the trend of stronger language models aligning more with vision just doesn't hold up for the newest models.
So the platonic mechanism is heavily contested.
It is. But we need to make something very clear to the listener here. This debate over the why does not rescue the Ross paper's findings.
Right. Because Ross and her team measured the correlated behavior empirically. Yes.
They observed it happening in the market simulation. They explicitly leave the exact mechanism to future work.
So even if the platonic story is totally wrong, it just changes the explanation. The dangerous result is still there.
Exactly. The models are still driving the car off the cliff together, regardless of why they all decided to turn the wheel at the same time.
Okay, but it can't be all doom and gloom, right? There has to be a scenario where having a bunch of smart AIs in a market is actually a good thing. Let's look at research question two.
Right, and here's where it gets really interesting. Are LLMs always destabilizing? No. When the shared reasoning is accurate, more LLM participation is incredibly good.
Okay, so walk me through the simulation they ran for this.
They built a single asset market simulation, and they used Claude Haiku 4.5, Claude Sonnet 4.6, and Gemini 2.0 Flashlight.
And these models are trading against noise traders and a fixed market maker.
Exactly. Over 100 rounds. And the fundamental value of the asset steps up from 100 to 120 at round 33 and then drops to 90 at round 66.
So they basically shock the system to see how the models react.
Yeah. And when the fundamental signal is accurate, the gap between market price and true value falls monotonically as you add more LLMs.
So they stabilize the market.
Big time. And a single behavioral parameter actually explains how they rank. It's called gap sensitivity lambda.
Gap sensitivity lambda. Basically how aggressively a model trades when it spots mispricing.
Exactly. Gemini trades the most aggressively per unit of mispricing. Its lambda is about 1.51, and because of that, it tracks the market best.
Then Sonnet.
Sonnet is the most conservative, lambda of about 1.15, and it tracks the worst. But as a whole, when the data is good, they make the system vastly more efficient.
Right, which perfectly sets up the climax of the paper research question three. What happens if these highly correlated models read the exact same bad news?
This is the reversal, the paper's sharpest finding.
Right. They injected eight pieces of rotating commentary into the simulation. And the commentary basically asserted that the fair value signal was overstating the true value by 25 to 30 percent.
So now every single agent is drawing from the same tainted information pool.
And what happens?
The stabilizing benefit doesn't just shrink. It completely inverts.
Oh, wow. And
then tracking error absolutely explodes. It reaches five to seven times the noise-only baseline at full LLM penetration.
Five to seven times worse than just having a bunch of random noise traders.
Yes. Directional accuracy collapses. Haiku drops to 54%. Gemini drops to 68%. And Sonic. Sonnet falls to 42%. Wait,
42% is literally below random chance.
Yes. Its orders became net contrarian. It was actively, confidently trading in the wrong direction.
That is insane. So a market of purely uninformed random noise traders is strictly better than a market of highly capable LLMs reading the same wrong story.
Strictly better. And we need to emphasize why this happens. Correlated reasoning errors, which come from shared context, are a qualitatively different and far worse failure mode than just correlated random noise.
Because with noise, some are guessing high, some are guessing low, and there's still some liquidity.
Exactly. But with LLMs, they aren't guessing. They are applying highly sophisticated reasoning to reach the exact same catastrophic conclusion.
OK, so what does this all mean for us outside the lab? Like, what are the actual consequences?
Well, the authors suggest we might need population level correlation audits.
Like how regulators monitor banks.
Exactly. Regulators don't just look at whether one single bank is safe. They watch systemic exposure across all institutions. Because if they all hold the same bad debt, the whole system crashes.
That's like the models holding the same implicit biases.
Right. Think about the 2010 flash crash.
Oh, right. Where algorithms wiped out like a trillion dollars in a few minutes.
Yeah. Those algorithms shared heuristics and synchronized catastrophically. But here's the scary part. LLM monoculture is much harder to spot. Because the 2010 crash was driven by shared explicit code, an auditor could look at it and say, ah, they're using the
same math. LLM correlation comes from shared implicit priors deep inside the neural network.
So it's totally invisible until it breaks.
Basically, yeah.
The authors also mentioned this brilliant example in the appendix about medical insurance billing.
Yes, the collective action problem.
Right. So you have hospitals using AI to write up billing codes to maximize their payouts. And then the insurance companies are using AI to audit those claims and deny them.
They're co-evolving. And as their capabilities rise, the correlation rises on both sides simultaneously.
Right. So the provider AIs all exploit the same loopholes and the payer AIs all aggressively deny the exact same things. It just creates massive systemic friction.
And no single hospital or insurance firm can fix it on their own. It is perfectly rational for an individual hospital to use the smartest model available.
But aggregate welfare for the whole healthcare system would be higher if we had a diverse, heterogeneous population of AIs that make different kinds of mistakes.
Exactly. But no single deployer is incentivized to use a worse model just to save the ecosystem.
Wow. Okay, before we wrap up, we do need to be completely honest about the limitations of this paper.
Yes, we definitely shouldn't oversell this as an established fact of Wall Street today.
Right. All the empirical evidence here is based on a simulated stylized single asset market.
With exogenous fundamentals and a fixed 0.5% spread from a market maker.
And real markets are way messier than that.
Endlessly messier. Real markets have correlated assets, endogenous liquidity, humans strategically adapting to algorithm behavior and super strict institutional constraints.
So whether these exact dynamics appear in live real-world markets is still an open empirical question.
The authors say that very plainly, yeah.
But still, the vulnerability is there. To summarize all this for you listening, making an AI smarter in isolation is inadvertently creating a hidden, non-diversifiable risk floor when these models gather in complex systems.
Because we only test the individual, never the crowd.
Exactly. Which leaves you with this final kind of provocative thought. If the smartest AIs of the future are destined to make the exact same brilliant deductions, but also the exact same catastrophic reasoning errors.
When the data is bad, yeah.
Right. Will the most valuable trait in future AI design stop being just raw intelligence? Like, will we have to start prioritizing engineered eccentricity?
Oh, that's an interesting phrase.
Like purposely designing models to think weirdly, just to ensure they don't agree with all the other machines when a flawed narrative hits the system. We might actually have to design them to be eccentric just to protect ourselves.
It really makes you rethink what a good AI even is.
It really does. Keep questioning the systems being built around you. And thanks for joining us on this deep dive.